okay we're in the front room the first
room in the Center for computing history
which is a Museum in Cambridge full of
lots of all Retro computers from around
about 1960 to present day so come with
me let's have a look around
so in front room we have various
different things going on here we have
apple two over there we have some of the
original Macs
we have an IBM PC in the corner but this
is kind of just off a little
introduction to the main event
just the main gallery down there we try
and get people in with some of the
interesting arcade machines we have over
here and so on before bringing them onto
the main stuff streetfighter here it's
always very popular people go straight
for that it's great when we have kids
coming and they come straight through
the doors over there and they just
straight over to this corner of the room
to the games over there before they even
see that we've got the main gallery next
door they quite like looking at the old
mobile phones to particularly the
massive briefcase style ones that we
have over there they're always good but
we have an oculus rift in the next room
along there which you can see someone
enjoying it at the moment but yeah if we
go through to the main gallery now we'll
show you the bulk of the collection so
people often they come to the front and
they don't expect this to be behind the
building a great big warehouse
essentially just full of all computers
most of them we have switched on and
playable we're trying to strike a
balance at the moment between being a
museum with interesting displays about
the history and so on and just having it
all there to see a biggest arcade
essentially feel just go out and play on
and enjoy there are plans to do lots of
new and interesting exhibitions in this
space but we always want to keep that
sense of it being somewhere just to come
in to use the old machines not just to
look at them gathering dust and so on we
want them to be used and enjoyed so over
here we have a lineup of various home
computers stretching well the latest one
we have here is the RISC PC and we go
back to the zx81 whenever we have school
groups in here it's always interesting
you say to them who's heard of this
iconic computer none of them have it's
it's almost sad but then you see the
teachers in the background going yeah
I've heard of it they always get it and
with the spectrum that we have over
there as well
they're the ones that that know what
we're talking about when it comes to
these old computers but it's good to
introduce the kids to it as well we do
try and kind of tell a Cambridge story
yeah this is probably the best place to
be in the country if you're going to set
up a museum of computers there's a lot
of computing heritage here the air for
instance we've done events we've had
Sinclair days and so on where we had
circa live Sinclair here last year to do
a kind of retrospective of his company
in his career and so on and see how it's
a good place to be if you want to talk
about computers yes it is yep arm are
one of our main supporters here actually
at the center so yeah we're very
grateful for all their help they've been
really good for us over the last few
years and they are again a very
important part of the history of
computing in this part of the country
okay all right let's go for a little
wander I think we've got kind of home
PCs and so on here but the games
consoles are probably the biggest drawer
in this room and we have those lined up
just over here so yeah we try to not go
too modern we don't want just to have
ps4 and Xbox ones in here we do have an
Xbox one upstairs but we're saving that
for kind of special events and so on but
the latest we go just day-to-day in the
gallery is the PlayStation 2 over here
about 10 years old is yeah the the
newest we want to go really because
otherwise yeah kids will come in and
they'll just run for the things they
know immediately rather than having a
look at the historical stuff so yeah
we've got all sorts we have a ps2 we
have the Gamecube Dreamcast n64 ps1 and
so on and then some slightly less
successful consoles like 3do and we have
of course pong you can't have a museum
of computers or games without pong of
some form pacman over there as well if
people want to play that and then around
the corner we have even more including a
nice bit of decoration we have a wall of
cassettes here which is quite good fun a
lot of people enjoy looking at that and
trying to spot some of the games from
their childhood I think this video might
be quite long if we spent the next few
minutes having a look to find it it
could be that so
here as well we have yeah we have Space
Invaders going on on the Atari VCS the
original Mario the original Prince of
Persia original Mario Kart so this stuff
over here proves very popular as well
when people come around the back and see
this there they're always having to go
and it's really good to see that
something like Super Mario Kart is still
as engaging as Mario Kart 8 is on the
Wii U there's probably not much
difference if we have them lined up next
to each other I think people would be
playing both you know it's really
interesting when you get younger
children in and at first you think are
they gonna go for some of this stuff
they do they really do a good game play
is always engaging and it's really
amazing to see we kind of step away from
the gaming side of things when we get
into this end of the museum and we're
going on to some slightly older machines
now we don't have as much switched on
down here partly because we are always
testing we're always trying to get
things to work there are repairs that
need to be done and so on but also
because as you can imagine the
electricity bill in a place like this is
quite high it goes off a bit
but we have still have some interesting
things over here we have SGI indigo over
hip which is quite an interesting
machine this one because of just the
graphics capabilities of a machine like
this in 1994 for its time in the early
90s this is top end kind of graphics
production and so on it's this is really
high-end stuff yeah it's basically just
the hard drive it's just some somewhere
in the depths of a system and you can
yeah
fly through files on that when it can't
load up so let's see we can't go back a
bit yeah it's not liking at the moment
I'm afraid but yeah you can essentially
you if you'll click on one file it would
generate another little landscape of the
files in there and the new folders and
you could sort of click through and fly
through the system it is yeah yeah it
wasn't just jammed up by a scriptwriter
it was a genuine application
[Music]
that just hasn't quite stood the test of
time really we had a few of these
machines lined up on our last retro
gaming night which is an event we hold
in here where we get loads more old
machines from the archive and then we
have four of these I think which in
their day would have been absolute
top-end desktops running really serious
applications worth thousands of pounds
at the time and we had four of them set
up playing quake so some people might
say that's a slight waste of computing
power but that's how things work around
here
we can have fun with it and play games
on them then we probably will but yeah
if we carry on down here we can have a
look at some more some of the slightly
older some a slightly bigger bits of
hardware we've got because although the
story is focused on home computing here
we try and cover a bit of the early days
of computing as well so we have
interesting mechanical calculators and
so on over here we have some military
machines that we've got lined up and
then we have the very earliest complete
machine that we have in the museum which
is this mini vac from 1961 and then yeah
we have various old business machines
and so on and all mainframes like this
computer here it's one of my favorite
things to do on school tours when we can
actually turn the elliot 9:03 on and
show kids that computers used to run on
paper it's not CDs or anything like that
paper was how you store things it's well
I'm I'm a gamer at heart that's my main
interest in this place I'm very tempted
to go and pick up a ps2 for 30 quid
somewhere and have a big retro binge at
one point so yeah that kind of era ps2
ps1 is my main thing but having done
lots of tours and so on the Elliott is
my favorite bit of the museum actually
it's just so much fun to switch it on
we get it playing music and knots and
crosses actually on the screen which is
always good fun and it's just such a fun
thing to do on school tours particularly
and guided tours of the museum is to
actually have one of these really old
machines up and running and working just
as it did it's a really interesting
thing to do
is the big reveal so this is the
internals of our serial number three and
it's quite drastically different it has
a simple circuit board inside just one
circuit board with all the components on
and it had this connector at the back
which allows you to increase it to a
massive 16 K of memory with that Ram
pack